Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. This episode is brought to you by Sky. So Dominic, we are talking about dragons today and I know that you are as excited as I am about the return of House of the Dragon because actually it's been two years, almost two years, since we last saw Matt Smith, Emma Darcy, Olivia Cooke on House of the Dragon and now they are returning for the biggest TV event of the summer. So more characters and, best of all, five new dragons.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本期节目由 Sky 赞助播出。多米尼克，今天我们要聊聊龙，我知道你和我一样，对《龙之家族》（House of the Dragon）的回归感到兴奋，因为距离我们上次在《龙之家族》中看到马特·史密斯、艾玛·达西和奥利维亚·库克已经过去两年了，几乎两年了。现在，他们正回归参与这个夏季最盛大的电视盛事。会有更多角色，最棒的是，还有五条新龙。
So Tom, you'll remember the big hullabaloo about King Aegon II's coronation and you'll remember what happened to his cousin, Lucerys Targaryen, murdered by a dragon. I do. So season two will see the much-anticipated civil war between the Greens and the Blacks unfold as, Tom, the dance of the dragons truly begins the realm is divided all of westeros must choose a side so please tune in
汤姆，你一定还记得关于伊耿二世国王加冕礼的那场大骚乱，也记得他的堂弟路斯里斯·瓦列利安遭遇了什么——被一条龙杀害。我记得。所以第二季将展现“绿党”与“黑党”之间备受期待的内战。汤姆，当龙之舞真正开始，整个王国陷入分裂，整个维斯特洛都必须选边站，所以请务必收看。
every monday and dominic there are so many questions who will win the war will team black or team green claim the iron throne which of these factions will triumph in the Dance of the Dragons? House of the Dragon is available now exclusively on Sky, and you can, of course, go to sky.com to find out more. A dragon is no idle fancy. Whatever may be his origins in fact or invention, the dragon in legend is a potent creation of men's imagination, richer in significance than his barrow is in gold. Even today, despite the critics,
每周一播出。多米尼克，有太多问题了：谁会赢得这场战争？是黑党还是绿党会坐上铁王座？这些派系中哪一方会在“龙之舞”中获胜？《龙之家族》现已在 Sky 独家上线，当然，你可以访问 sky.com 了解更多信息。龙绝非空想。无论其起源是事实还是虚构，传说中的龙都是人类想象力的强大产物，其意义远比它巢穴中的黄金更为丰富。即使在今天，尽管有评论家，
you may find men not ignorant of tragic legend and history, who have heard of heroes and indeed seen them, who have yet been caught by the fascination of the worm. That was, of course, J.R.R. Tolkien in his great essay, Beowulf, the Monsters and the Critics, which he published in 1936. And Tom, that was an essay that changed the way people thought about Anglo-Saxon literature, about fantasy literature more generally, I suppose, but also about dragons. Yeah, absolutely. So he talks about people who've been caught by the fascination of the worm. He does indeed.
你可能还是会发现一些人，他们并非对悲剧传说和历史一无所知，他们听说过英雄，甚至见过英雄，却依然被这种“蠕虫”的魅力所吸引。这当然是 J.R.R. 托尔金在他 1936 年发表的伟大论文《贝奥武夫：怪兽与评论家》中所说的。汤姆，那篇论文改变了人们对盎格鲁-撒克逊文学的看法，我想也改变了对奇幻文学的看法，当然还有对龙的看法。是的，绝对是。所以他谈到了那些被“蠕虫”的魅力所吸引的人。他确实是这么说的。
And I think pretty clearly there, he's talking about himself. He's obviously a man who is obsessed by dragons. But since Tolkien wrote that essay, dragons have gone completely mainstream, in part at least thanks to Tolkien himself. But more recently due to the global phenomenon that is Game of Thrones and House of the Dragon. So the novels first by George R.R. Martin and then the TV series. So people were very excited when Game of Thrones first came out. I remember watching it, what is it, 10 years ago or something. The dragons in Game of Thrones, when they start off, dragons are extinct or they're thought to have vanished and they're in these eggs. And then they hatch at the end of the first series.
我认为他在那里很明显是在谈论他自己。他显然是一个痴迷于龙的人。但自从托尔金写了那篇论文后，龙已经完全进入了主流，这至少部分归功于托尔金本人。但更近一点说，是因为《权力的游戏》和《龙之家族》这一全球现象。也就是乔治·R·R·马丁的小说，然后是电视剧。所以当《权力的游戏》刚出来时，人们非常兴奋。我记得我是在，是什么时候，10年前左右看的。《权力的游戏》里的龙，刚开始时，龙已经灭绝了，或者被认为已经消失了，它们在这些蛋里。然后在第一季结束时它们孵化了。
And they're quite sweet, aren't they? To begin with. They are. Kind of little baby dragons. terms was groundbreaking because the cgi used for the dragons was extraordinary i mean it was the first time anyone had done anything like this that didn't look a little bit fake and actually as the series went on the dragons became more and more important because they sort of played the part of well we were talking about this before we started recording weren't we about whether or not the dragons can be likened to weapons of mass destruction and at the end of game of thrones
它们很可爱，不是吗？起初是这样。是的。就像小龙宝宝一样。《权力的游戏》具有开创性，因为用于龙的 CGI 非常非凡。我的意思是，这是第一次有人做出看起来不那么虚假的东西。而且随着剧集的推进，龙变得越来越重要，因为它们扮演的角色……嗯，我们在录制前就在讨论这个问题，不是吗？关于龙是否可以被比作大规模杀伤性武器。在《权力的游戏》结尾，
without giving it away to people who haven't well actually if you read the books you haven't got to the end but if you've seen the tv series the dragon's sort of full potential is exploited in a terrifying way. Yeah, unleashed in a kind of apocalyptic manner. And the reason that we're recording this is that today, going out on Sky, is House of the Dragon. So Series 1 has already gone out and now series two is coming out. And in that series, which you can see on Sky, House of the Dragon is, well, do you know what? We're being sponsored by Sky. Let's be upfront. I hope that they will allow me to say that it is quite like Henry VI part one, the Shakespeare play that shows us the opening of the Wars of the Roses. So it's like the Wars of the Roses.
在不剧透给那些还没看的人的情况下——好吧，其实如果你读过书，你还没看到结尾，但如果你看过电视剧，龙的全部潜力以一种可怕的方式被利用了。是的，以一种末日般的方式释放了出来。我们录制这期节目的原因是，今天在 Sky 上线的是《龙之家族》。第一季已经播出了，现在第二季要出来了。在这一季中，你可以在 Sky 上看到，《龙之家族》是……你知道吗？我们是由 Sky 赞助的。我们坦诚一点。我希望他们允许我说，它很像莎士比亚的剧作《亨利六世（第一部）》，它向我们展示了玫瑰战争的开端。所以它就像玫瑰战争。
It's very, very Shakespearean, kind of rival noble families quarreling over the crown. So it's like Shakespeare, only you don't know what's going to happen. And as the name implies, it has a lot of dragons. Right. So the dragons in House of the Dragon, it's not like in Game of Thrones where there's the mother of dragons And she has three dragons And that makes her a remarkable figure in the context of this world, Westeros But in House of the Dragon There's a sort of nuclear proliferation, isn't there, of dragons?
它非常有莎士比亚风格，就像敌对的贵族家庭为了王冠而争吵。所以它就像莎士比亚的作品，只是你不知道会发生什么。正如名字所暗示的那样，它有很多龙。没错。所以《龙之家族》里的龙，不像《权力的游戏》里那样，有一个龙之母，她有三条龙，这使她在维斯特洛这个世界背景下成为一个非凡的人物。但在《龙之家族》中，龙有一种核扩散，不是吗？
And I think that dragons kind of play the role of tactical nuclear weapons So battlefield nuclear weapons And we see the origins of the family of Daenerys, the mother of dragons. So it's the Targaryens. They have come from overseas. They've brought their dragons with them. And this has enabled them to conquer the continent of Westeros. And basically the plot of House of the Dragon is civil war within the Targaryen family. And it ends up, so the end of series one, one of the rival candidates, who is a Targaryen herself and can ride a dragon, is wondering whether she should fight to defend her right to the throne. Because she knows what it will mean. And there are these
我认为龙扮演了战术核武器的角色，也就是战场核武器。我们看到了龙之母丹妮莉丝家族的起源。也就是坦格利安家族。他们从海外而来，带来了他们的龙。这使他们能够征服维斯特洛大陆。基本上《龙之家族》的情节就是坦格利安家族内部的内战。故事的结尾，第一季结束时，其中一位竞争者，她本人也是坦格利安人，可以骑龙，正在考虑她是否应该为了捍卫自己的王位权利而战。因为她知道这意味着什么。而且有这些
very, very kind of chilling lines that you get in the final episode of series one when dragons flew to war before so she's talking about what has happened even before this everything burned i do not wish to rule over a kingdom of ash and bone and you see in the final stages of season one you see how dragons actually can't be controlled even by the people who who supposedly can ride them and i'm guessing that people listening to this there there will either be massive enthusiasm. I mean, Game of Thrones was a huge global phenomenon and House of Dragons had a massive critical success as well. But there will also be kind of bewilderment.
在第一季最后一集中，有一些非常令人不寒而栗的台词：“龙以前也曾飞向战争”，所以她在谈论甚至在此之前发生的事情，“一切都化为灰烬，我不想统治一个灰烬与白骨的王国。”在第一季的最后阶段，你会看到龙实际上是无法被控制的，即使是被那些理应能骑它们的人。我猜听这个节目的人，要么会充满热情。我的意思是，《权力的游戏》是一个巨大的全球现象，《龙之家族》也取得了巨大的评论成功。但也会有一种困惑。
Because there are lots of people, Tom, who would say, listening to this, say, oh, in a history podcast, dragons, really? And actually, that itself is a historical phenomenon, because Tolkien, in 1936, correct and sober taste may refuse to admit that there can be an interest for us, the proud we that includes all intelligent living people, in ogres and dragons. And actually, Tolkien, when he wrote that essay in the 30s, was saying, as a society, we have become indifferent to, we've lost sight of the, dare I say, the weirdness, Tom, of monsters, of dragons, and that we think of them as childish,
因为汤姆，有很多人听了会说，哦，在历史播客里聊龙，真的吗？实际上，这本身就是一个历史现象，因为托尔金在 1936 年曾说：“正确且清醒的品味可能会拒绝承认，我们——这个‘我们’包含了所有有智慧的活人——会对食人魔和龙产生兴趣。”实际上，托尔金在 30 年代写那篇论文时是在说，作为一个社会，我们已经变得漠不关心，我们已经失去了对——我敢说——怪兽和龙的怪异性的关注，汤姆，我们认为它们是幼稚的，
but actually they are a really, really interesting and important cultural and historical phenomenon that opens up all kinds of different avenues of inquiry. Well, the amazing thing is, is that even George R. R. Martin, the novelist who created Game of Thrones, even he had to be persuaded to include dragons. So it was his friend, the writer Phyllis Eisenstein, wrote to him and said, George, it's a fantasy. You've got to have dragons. George R.R. Martin was doing the Wars of the Roses, basically, Lannisters and Starks, Lancaster and York. And I suppose he had an anxiety that putting dragons in it would mean that people thought it was childish, that it was silly and frivolous. But as we'll discover, there's nothing frivolous about dragons at all, is there? Well, I think also from the historical point of view,
但实际上它们是一个非常、非常有趣且重要的文化和历史现象，开启了各种不同的探究途径。嗯，令人惊奇的是，即使是创造了《权力的游戏》的小说家乔治·R·R·马丁，甚至他也必须被说服去加入龙。所以是他的朋友，作家菲利斯·艾森斯坦写信给他，说：“乔治，这是奇幻小说。你必须有龙。”乔治·R·R·马丁当时基本上是在写玫瑰战争，兰尼斯特和史塔克，兰开斯特和约克。我想他可能担心加入龙会让人们觉得它很幼稚，觉得它很傻、很轻浮。但正如我们将要发现的那样，龙一点也不轻浮，对吧？嗯，我认为从历史的角度来看，
so looking at the dragon as a cultural phenomenon, there is a really obvious, strange factor about it, which obviously dragons are fantasy. I mean, there's no disputing that. Although I think secretly Tolkien kind of did believe that they might have existed. He kind of drops hints about that in that essay that you were quoting. But the weird thing is, is that basically everyone kind of knows what they look like, even though they never existed. So you know that they're reptilian, that they kind of have scales, that they have lidless eyes, that they have a flickering tongue. You know that they're long and snake-like, or lidless eyes, that they have a flickering tongue. You know that they're long and snake-like, or you might say worm-like. So Tolkien in that passage quoted the worm.
观察龙作为一种文化现象，有一个非常明显、奇怪的因素，显然龙是奇幻的。我的意思是，这一点毫无争议。虽然我认为托尔金私下里确实相信它们可能存在过。他在你引用的那篇论文中暗示了这一点。但奇怪的是，基本上每个人都知道它们长什么样，尽管它们从未存在过。所以你知道它们是爬行动物，它们有鳞片，它们有无眼睑的眼睛，它们有颤动的舌头。你知道它们又长又像蛇，或者你可能会说像蠕虫。所以托尔金在那个段落中引用了“蠕虫”。
That they breathe fire, that they have wings, that they can fly, that they have legs. Okay, just on legs. Two or four, Tom, because that is, among dragonologists, that is a crucial area of contention, isn't it? Whether a dragon has two or four legs. Actually, specifically among British heralds, which we'll come to. So for British heraldry, a two-legged dragon is a wyvern and a four-legged dragon is a dragon. We'll be coming to that. And Martin's dragons, so the dragons that you see in the House of the Dragon, are kind of midway between that. So we'll be discussing that.
它们喷火，它们有翅膀，它们会飞，它们有腿。好吧，关于腿。两条还是四条，汤姆？因为在龙学家中，这是一个至关重要的争论点，不是吗？龙是有两条腿还是四条腿。实际上，特别是在英国纹章官中，我们稍后会谈到。所以对于英国纹章学来说，两条腿的龙是双足飞龙（wyvern），四条腿的龙是龙（dragon）。我们稍后会谈到。而马丁的龙，也就是你在《龙之家族》中看到的龙，介于两者之间。所以我们会讨论这个问题。
Not quite three-legged, but... Yeah. So everyone kind of, you know, if you said, what's a dragon to someone in the West, they'd immediately know it. But the even weirder thing is, is that dragons are not confined to kind of medieval Europe. When people think of dragons, they think of China, don't they? But there are dragons also in... There are effectively dragons in Greek myths and Babylonian legends and so on.
不完全是三条腿，但是……是的。所以每个人，你知道，如果你对西方人说“什么是龙”，他们会立刻知道。但更奇怪的是，龙并不局限于中世纪的欧洲。当人们想到龙时，他们会想到中国，不是吗？但龙也存在于……希腊神话和巴比伦传说中实际上也有龙，等等。
Yeah, and Egyptian. So you could say it's kind of pretty much a global phenomenon. So that raises the obvious question. Where is this idea coming from? It can't just be kind of cross-cultural contamination because the Chinese are coming up with it at the same time as the Babylonians are, and they don't know each other.
是的，还有埃及。所以你可以说这几乎是一个全球性的现象。这就提出了一个显而易见的问题：这个想法是从哪里来的？这不可能是跨文化的污染，因为中国人在巴比伦人产生这个想法的同时也产生了它，而他们彼此并不认识。
So an obvious theory, Tom, I don't want to send you into a seven-hour lecture about this because I know this is your specialist subject, but an obvious theory would be that there's some kind of weirdly buried cultural memory of dinosaurs. Which is, I mean, it so ticks my boxes. And I would so love that to be true. And it was actually, it was proposed by Carl Sagan. Oh, yeah.
所以一个显而易见的理论，汤姆，我不想让你进行七小时的讲座，因为我知道这是你的专业领域，但一个显而易见的理论是，某种奇怪的、被埋藏的恐龙文化记忆。这，我的意思是，非常符合我的胃口。我非常希望这是真的。实际上，这是卡尔·萨根提出的。哦，是的。
He's the former great popularizer of science. And he wrote a book with the brilliant title The Dragons of Eden, where he proposes that the kind of seeming universality of the dragon as a myth is a kind of legacy of our primordial ancestry in Mesozoic ecosystems when we were tiny little shrews kind of dodging tyrannosaurs. How would that have been passed down though in pre-linguistic age? So I think it's fair to say that that hasn't met with universal enthusiasm among scientists. So we're not the rest of science, are we, Dominic? Never. I don't feel we're qualified to say about that. But there is also another thesis that the discovery of dragon fossils might have inspired it.
他是前伟大的科学普及者。他写了一本名为《伊甸园的龙》的精彩书籍，他在书中提出，龙作为神话的这种看似普遍性，是我们中生代生态系统中原始祖先的一种遗产，当时我们是躲避霸王龙的小鼩鼱。但这在语言前时代是如何传承下来的呢？所以我认为公平地说，这在科学家中并没有得到普遍的热情。所以我们不是科学界的其余部分，对吧，多米尼克？从来都不是。我觉得我们没有资格对此发表评论。但还有另一种理论，即龙化石的发现可能启发了它。
And there's a brilliant series of books by a scholar called Adrian Mayer who pursues this theme. And I think that actually there is a kind of definite case for this in the case of China and Mongolia, because there are quite a lot of dinosaur fossils that you find there kind of weathering out of the rocks. And you can kind of see how that might be something that might have worked. And we also do have kind of examples in the might be something that might have worked. And we also do have kind of examples in the Mediterranean world. You'll make plenty, plenty of the elder. We can't have an episode on mad kind of wonders without mentioning Pliny. Yeah, so he writes about a Roman general who was in the train of Pompey the Great,
有一位名叫阿德里安·梅耶的学者写了一系列精彩的书，探讨了这个主题。我认为在中国和蒙古的情况下，这确实有明确的依据，因为你在那里确实能发现很多从岩石中风化出来的恐龙化石。你可以看出这可能是如何起作用的。而且我们在地中海世界也有类似的例子。你会提到老普林尼。我们不能在不提到普林尼的情况下做一期关于疯狂奇迹的节目。是的，他写了一位庞培大帝麾下的罗马将军，
who was campaigning in the East in the 50s BC. And in 58 BC, he comes back from the East. He's coming back from what's now Lebanon and Israel. And he exhibits in Rome the bones of a giant beast found at Joppa, which is now Jaffa. And Pliny records that this was 40 feet long, that it had ribs longer than those of an African elephant. And the assumption is that this is a sea monster that had been turned to stone by Perseus, who was the legendary hero. With the head of Medusa.
他在公元前 50 年代在东方作战。公元前 58 年，他从东方回来。他从现在的黎巴嫩和以色列回来。他在罗马展示了在雅法（Joppa，现在的 Jaffa）发现的一只巨兽的骨头。普林尼记录说这东西有 40 英尺长，肋骨比非洲象的还要长。推测这是一种被珀尔修斯（传说中的英雄）石化的海怪。用美杜莎的头。
With the head of Medusa. I love that theory. Yeah, and had rescued the princess Andromeda. Yeah. So this was the theory. And then there is another much more recent example of this happening, which happened in late medieval Austria.
用美杜莎的头。我喜欢那个理论。是的，而且救了安德洛墨达公主。是的。所以这就是那个理论。然后还有另一个最近得多的例子，发生在晚中世纪的奥地利。
Yeah, I love an Austrian dragon. The town of Klagenfurt. So where in the 13th century, which is very late, there's reports that a dragon was kind of wrecking havoc as dragons tend to do. And the local duke offers a reward for anyone who could capture it and kill it. And so a brave young man gets a bull, chains it up, and he kind of has a hook on the chain and he catches the dragon like a fish. Fishing with a bull as bait. Yeah.
是的，我喜欢奥地利的龙。克拉根福镇。在 13 世纪，这已经很晚了，有报道称一条龙正在肆虐，正如龙往往会做的那样。当地公爵悬赏任何能抓住并杀死它的人。于是，一个勇敢的年轻人找来一头公牛，把它拴住，他在链子上装了一个钩子，像钓鱼一样钓到了龙。用公牛做诱饵钓鱼。是的。
And he kills it. And then what turbo charges this? A huge excitement. 1355. People are digging around in a cave and it's called the Dragon's Cave. And they find what seems to be the skull of the dragon. And they bring it out. It's made of stone and they
他杀死了它。然后是什么让这变得更加火爆？巨大的兴奋。1355 年。人们在山洞里挖掘，那个洞被称为“龙洞”。他们发现了看起来像是龙的头骨的东西。他们把它带了出来。它是石头做的，他们
store it in the, it's kind of exhibited in the town hall. It's one of the great wonders of Klagenfurt. And in 1590, the town fathers commission a statue of this dragon and the sculptor goes to look at this skull and he models the head of the dragon on the contours of the skull. So it is reputed to be the first reconstruction of a prehistoric creature actually looking at the bones. But the question is, was that skull the skull of a dinosaur? Am I not right in thinking that actually neither of these collections of bones were dinosaurs? So the Pliny's thing, or whatever it is, that's a whale, isn't it? Yeah, basically there are no dinosaurs to be found in this region. And sea monsters don't actually exist.
把它存放在……它在市政厅展出。它是克拉根福的伟大奇迹之一。1590 年，镇上的长者委托制作了一座龙的雕像，雕塑家去看了这个头骨，并根据头骨的轮廓塑造了龙的头部。所以它被认为是史前生物的第一次重建，实际上是看着骨头做的。但问题是，那个头骨是恐龙的头骨吗？我没记错的话，实际上这些骨头收藏都不是恐龙的，对吧？所以普林尼的那个东西，或者不管它是什么，那是鲸鱼，对吧？是的，基本上那个地区没有恐龙。而且海怪实际上并不存在。
Yeah, and the, yes, that as well. But no, but it might have been a kind of, you know, a tyrannosaur head or something like that. And the dragon in the cave? Is a woolly rhinoceros. Also, of course, the issue with the fossils theory is that, so for example, dragons play a huge part, as we will go on to see in Norse sagas and things, don't they? Worms and whatnot. But there aren't big fossils of dinosaurs in Scandinavia. So have they just, where's it come from? Right. So I think that theory, I mean,
是的，还有那个。但不是，它可能是一种，你知道，霸王龙的头之类的东西。那山洞里的龙呢？是披毛犀。当然，化石理论的问题在于，例如，龙在北欧萨迦等文学中扮演了重要角色，正如我们稍后会看到的，蠕虫之类的。但在斯堪的纳维亚半岛并没有大型恐龙化石。所以它们是从哪里来的？没错。所以我认为那个理论，我的意思是，
the kind of elements of truth to it, but I think that there are, you know, it's inadequate to explain the whole phenomenon. And so what a lot of anthropologists and also Jungian psychologists who love an archetype, they have proposed that dragons are an expression of the dread of the violence and danger of nature. And I think it's interesting that you get these legends emerging in Egypt, in Babylon, in China, all of which are kind of river-based civilizations and therefore might be subject to violent flooding. So perhaps that explains why these stories are kind of appearing specifically in these locations. And could you argue as well, that's why we're interested in dragons right now? The idea of the world being reduced to ash, the idea of fire and the climate
它有真理的成分，但我认为它不足以解释整个现象。所以很多人类学家，还有喜欢原型的荣格心理学家，他们提出龙是对自然暴力和危险的恐惧的表达。我认为有趣的是，这些传说出现在埃及、巴比伦、中国，所有这些都是河流文明，因此可能遭受严重的洪水。所以也许这解释了为什么这些故事会特别出现在这些地方。你也可以争辩说，这就是为什么我们现在对龙感兴趣的原因吗？世界化为灰烬的想法，火和气候的想法
crisis and all that stuff. People are more receptive to that idea. Yeah, that's a really interesting point. But I think the argument from anthropologists would be that it could also be a reminder of an age when humans were the prey rather than the predator. And perhaps this is what explains the kind of reptilian and particularly serpentine quality of dragons. Yeah, because everybody hates a snake. Well, as we go on to see, not everybody hates a snake.
危机等等。人们对这个想法更易于接受。是的，这是一个非常有趣的观点。但我认为人类学家的论点是，它也可能提醒人们，人类曾经是猎物而不是捕食者。也许这就是解释龙的爬行动物特征，特别是蛇形特征的原因。是的，因为每个人都讨厌蛇。好吧，正如我们稍后会看到的，并不是每个人都讨厌蛇。
Tom, I hate snakes. I have no time for snakes. I hold them in very low regard, like Indiana Jones. And actually, there's... I don't mind a snake. You don't mind a snake? No, I don't mind a snake. Would you have a snake hung around your shoulders?
汤姆，我讨厌蛇。我没时间理会蛇。我像印第安纳·琼斯一样非常看不起它们。实际上，有……我不介意蛇。你不介意蛇？不，我不介意蛇。你会让蛇挂在你的肩膀上吗？
Would you welcome that? I think if I wanted to intimidate people. But if you were strolling through the souks of Marrakesh and a barker hung a snake around your shoulders... I'd be fine with that. You know, I'd quite welcome to my home and I would... the lord of snakes or something. The lord of snakes. shoulders. I'd be fine with that. You know, I quite... I'd hate that. Welcome to my home, and I would... The Lord of Snakes or something. The Lord of Snakes.
你会欢迎吗？我想如果我想恐吓人们的话。但如果你在马拉喀什的露天市场漫步，一个摊贩把一条蛇挂在你的肩膀上……我会没事的。你知道，我会很欢迎它来到我家，我会……蛇之主之类的。蛇之主。肩膀上。我会没事的。你知道，我相当……我会讨厌那样。欢迎来到我家，我会……蛇之主之类的。蛇之主。
Yeah, I quite go for that. That's how you'll be known from now on. So we've mentioned how Tolkien refers to dragons as worms. The old English for dragon was a worm. That was lovely. I really enjoyed that. And in Old Norse, it's an urm. Yeah.
是的，我相当喜欢那样。从现在起你就会以这个名字闻名了。我们提到了托尔金是如何将龙称为“蠕虫”（worms）的。古英语中龙就是“蠕虫”。那太可爱了。我真的很喜欢。在古诺斯语中，它是“urm”。是的。
You're pretty good at rolling your eyes. Yeah. And actually, in House of the Dragon, the dragon ridden by the character played by matt smith yeah erstwhile doctor who and duke of edinburgh yeah um is called the blood worm so does he say it like that yeah he does so the way in which dragons are serpentine in in most of the myths so they live in holes so you get this in House of the Dragon, they live in dragon pits or caves. They're lidless and snakes have no eyelids. They can't close their eyes. And so when you look at a snake, it's unblinking, it's quite intimidating.
你很擅长翻白眼。是的。实际上，在《龙之家族》中，由马特·史密斯（前《神秘博士》和爱丁堡公爵）饰演的角色所骑的龙，叫“血虫”（the blood worm）。所以他会那样说吗？是的，他会。所以龙在大多数神话中呈蛇形的方式，它们住在洞里，所以你在《龙之家族》中也会看到，它们住在龙穴或洞穴里。它们没有眼睑，蛇没有眼睑。它们不能闭上眼睛。所以当你看着蛇时，它是不眨眼的，这相当吓人。
And of course, a lot of snakes are poisonous. And I think it's pretty clear that that's where the idea of fire comes from, the idea of poison coming out of the mouths. So I think that's all very convincing, but it still doesn't entirely get to the root of the issue of where the dragon that you get in the House of the Dragon, the Western dragon, is coming from. Because not all dragons are fundamentally like snakes you know they have other attributes they have wings they have legs and also dragons are terrifying right and snakes are obviously not always terrifying because sometimes i know you're you love a greek snake don't you and greek snakes they can be wise and benevolent? Well, they can be. So there's a sacred snake on the Acropolis in Athens,
当然，很多蛇是有毒的。我认为很明显，这就是火的想法的来源，即毒液从嘴里喷出的想法。所以我认为这一切都很有说服力，但它仍然没有完全触及《龙之家族》中那种西方龙的起源问题。因为并非所有的龙本质上都像蛇，你知道，它们有其他属性，它们有翅膀，它们有腿。而且龙很可怕，对吧？而蛇显然并不总是可怕的，因为有时我知道你喜欢希腊蛇，不是吗？希腊蛇可以是智慧和仁慈的？嗯，它们可以是。所以雅典卫城上有一条神圣的蛇，
and girls feed it with honey cakes. And when the Persians invade in 480 BC and burn Athens, the coming incineration of the Acropolis is foretold by the sacred snake vanishing. And, of course, you have Asclepius, the god of healing. One of his symbols is snakes coiled around a staff. You've got a wound or a sore. He'll get a snake to come and lick it for you.
女孩们用蜂蜜蛋糕喂它。当波斯人在公元前 480 年入侵并烧毁雅典时，卫城即将被焚毁的预兆就是那条神圣的蛇消失了。当然，还有阿斯克勒庇俄斯，治愈之神。他的标志之一就是缠绕在手杖上的蛇。如果你有伤口或溃疡，他会让蛇来为你舔舐。
Yeah, you go and lie down at the temple of Asclepius and the holy snakes will come out and lick your wounds. If you had to choose between having a snake, if you had an open wound and you could have a snake come and lick it or Catherine of Siena suck at it, which would you go for? I think I'd go for the snake. Would you? Yeah, they'd be sweet little snakes.
是的，你去阿斯克勒庇俄斯神庙躺下，神圣的蛇就会出来舔你的伤口。如果你必须在让蛇来舔你的开放性伤口和让锡耶纳的凯瑟琳来吸吮它之间做出选择，你会选哪个？我想我会选蛇。真的吗？是的，它们会是可爱的小蛇。
Yeah, I don't like snakes. I don't massively like Catherine of Siena. But you're a big fan of Constantinople as well, aren't you? Love Constantinople. So in Byzantium, the city that Constantinople will be built on, no one was allowed to attack a snake, to kill a snake. So St. Patrick would have been unwelcome. Very unwelcome. Because snakes are seen by the Byzantines as benefactors of the city.
是的，我不喜欢蛇。我也不太喜欢锡耶纳的凯瑟琳。但你也是君士坦丁堡的忠实粉丝，不是吗？热爱君士坦丁堡。所以在拜占庭，也就是君士坦丁堡建立的城市，没有人被允许攻击蛇，杀死蛇。所以圣帕特里克在那里会不受欢迎。非常不受欢迎。因为蛇被拜占庭人视为城市的恩人。
Yeah. So that's one tradition, obviously, where snakes are seen as quite positive. But what about dragons? Of course, there is a very, very well-known dragon tradition in which dragons are Great pals. Very, very beneficent. And that of course is the Chinese tradition. So the Chinese, the dragon brings rain. If you're a good emperor, the dragon is a great chum of yours. And the dragon generally symbolizes sort of balance and wellbeing and sort of national prosperity and stuff like that, right? They are absolutely not wicked. I mean, quite the opposite.
是的。所以这是一种传统，显然蛇被视为相当积极的。但龙呢？当然，有一个非常、非常著名的龙传统，其中龙是好伙伴。非常、非常仁慈。那当然就是中国传统。所以在中国，龙带来雨水。如果你是一个好皇帝，龙就是你的好哥们。而且龙通常象征着平衡、福祉和国家繁荣之类的东西，对吧？它们绝对不是邪恶的。我的意思是，恰恰相反。
As you say, they are symbols of that kind of sense of harmony that in a sense lies at the heart of Chinese civilization. And they are also incredibly old. So there are portrayals of what seem to be dragons that go right the way back to the Neolithic. So, you know, thousands and thousands of years ago. And all the way through the histories of China, I mean, right the way up to the present day, emperors are being visited by dragons.
正如你所说，它们是那种和谐感的象征，在某种意义上，这种和谐感是中国文明的核心。而且它们也非常古老。所以有看起来像是龙的描绘，一直追溯到新石器时代。所以，你知道，几千年前。在整个中国历史中，我的意思是，一直到今天，皇帝们都会受到龙的造访。
There's a sense in which dragons, I think, you know, people in China really do seem to have believed that dragons existed. They're not seen as merely fantastical. And there's an incredibly recent example of that. So Yuan Shikai, who is one of the kind of the leading figures in the revolutionary movement that ends up toppling the empire in the 1910s. In 1915, he decides it's all been a terrible mistake. They should bring back the emperor and he nominates himself to be the emperor. And he actually makes an attempt to kind of unearth the bones of a dragon to demonstrate that in some way he has been chosen
有一种感觉，我认为，你知道，中国的人们似乎真的相信龙存在过。它们不仅仅被视为虚构的。有一个非常近期的例子。袁世凯，他是 1910 年代推翻帝制的革命运动中的领军人物之一。1915 年，他认为这一切都是一个可怕的错误。他们应该恢复帝制，他提名自己为皇帝。他实际上试图挖掘龙骨，以证明他在某种程度上是被选中的
as emperor. And he's casting his rule as something that because it's been blessed by a dragon, therefore, yeah, brilliant. Maybe emperor. Does he find the dragon bones? No, he doesn't. He doesn't. I don't think he has time to look for it. Right. So that Chinese tradition is obviously very, very different to the Westerosi tradition that you get. And so, you know, we come back to this question,
皇帝。他把自己的统治塑造成一种因为受到龙的祝福，所以……是的，太棒了。也许是皇帝。他找到龙骨了吗？不，他没有。他没有。我不认为他有时间去找。没错。所以那个中国传统显然与你在维斯特洛看到的传统非常、非常不同。所以，你知道，我们回到这个问题，
where is that, you know, the fire-breathing, winged, hostile dragon coming from? And I think that you can actually trace it back to a very obvious point of origin and it's Tolkien. Oh yeah I mean when I think about when would I first encounter dragons you know as a boy I guess they're in children's literature generally but they're only in children's aren't they really after The Hobbit. Yeah so The Hobbit is famously Tolkien starts writing it in the early 1920s when he's marking school certificate papers
那个喷火、有翅膀、敌对的龙是从哪里来的？我认为你实际上可以把它追溯到一个非常明显的起源点，那就是托尔金。哦，是的。我的意思是，当我想到我第一次接触龙是什么时候，你知道，作为一个男孩，我想它们通常出现在儿童文学中，但它们只有在《霍比特人》之后才出现在儿童文学中，不是吗？是的，《霍比特人》很有名，托尔金在 20 世纪 20 年代初开始写它，当时他正在批改学校证书试卷，
after he's come home from the First World War. He's at Oxford and he sits down, he writes in the Hall of the Grounds that there lived a hobbit. And for people who don't know, which I can't believe is anybody, this guy Bilbo Baggins, he's a burglar. He goes off with some dwarves and a wizard and they're going to find this lost treasure in the Lonely Mountain, which is guarded by the dragon Smaug. And the whole trajectory of the narrative is leading up to the great confrontation between Bilbo, our hero, and the Dragon Smaug, who is actually a tremendous character. Yeah. He's like he's voiced by George Sanders or Terry Thomas, isn't he?
在他从第一次世界大战回家后。他在牛津，他坐下来，在试卷上写道：“在地下的一个洞里住着一个霍比特人。”对于那些不知道的人——我不敢相信还有人不知道——这个叫比尔博·巴金斯的家伙，他是个飞贼。他和一些矮人和一个巫师出发，他们要去找回那个在孤山中丢失的宝藏，那里由龙史矛革守护。整个叙事轨迹都指向比尔博，我们的英雄，与龙史矛革之间的伟大对决，史矛革实际上是一个了不起的角色。是的。他是由乔治·桑德斯或特里·托马斯配音的，不是吗？
Sort of, hello. Or Benedict Cumberbatch in the film. Yeah, he's very, but actually in the film, he's threatening and his voice is very deep and stuff. But in the book. Hello. Yes, he's very but actually in the film he's he's threatening and and his voice is very deep and stuff but in the book hello yes he's right he's rather suave and urbane and witty yeah and so so that obviously is drawing on kind of traditions that's current in the 1930s but tolkien is the great scholar of norse and old english literature and mythology. And he is very, very consciously drawing on these traditions for his portrayal of dragons. Well, there are two in particular, aren't there?
有点像，“你好。”或者电影里的本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇。是的，他非常……但在电影里，他很有威胁性，他的声音很深沉之类的。但在书里。你好。是的，他非常……但在电影里，他很有威胁性，他的声音很深沉之类的。但在书里，你好，是的，他相当温文尔雅、风趣幽默。是的，所以这显然借鉴了 1930 年代流行的传统，但托尔金是诺斯语和古英语文学及神话的伟大学者。他非常、非常自觉地借鉴了这些传统来塑造他的龙。嗯，有两个特别的，不是吗？
There are two dragons that basically influence Smaug. So tell us about those two dragons. Well, he says in Northern literature, there are only two dragons that are significant. And the first of these is a dragon called Fafnir. And this is part of a kind of vast corpus of Norse legends that Tolkien is completely fascinated by. And basically in this is part of a kind of vast corpus of Norse legends that Tolkien is completely fascinated by. And basically in this, there is a dwarf who has killed his father, who steals his
有两个龙基本上影响了史矛革。所以告诉我们那两条龙。嗯，他在北欧文学中说，只有两条龙是重要的。第一条龙叫法夫纳（Fafnir）。这是托尔金完全着迷的一种庞大的诺斯传说语料库的一部分。基本上，这是……这是托尔金完全着迷的一种庞大的诺斯传说语料库的一部分。基本上，在这里，有一个矮人杀死了他的父亲，偷走了他的
treasure, who hides it in a cave, who squats down on this treasure. And over the course of time, he becomes a wyrm. A wyrm. I mean, a dragon. Maggie Smith joining us here. Yeah. And his brother, who's very cross about this. Oh yeah, Regan. Yeah, Regan. So he forges a great sword and Wagner fans, this is kind of one of the great moments in the Ring Cycle. And he persuades the hero Sigurd, or Siegfried if you're watching Wagner, to take the sword and to dig a trench which kind of runs by the water where Fafnir comes down to drink.
宝藏，把它藏在洞穴里，蹲在这个宝藏上。随着时间的推移，他变成了一条“蠕虫”（wyrm）。一条蠕虫。我的意思是，一条龙。玛吉·史密斯加入我们了。是的。还有他的兄弟，对此非常生气。哦，是的，雷金（Regin）。是的。所以他锻造了一把伟大的剑，瓦格纳的粉丝们，这是《指环》中的伟大时刻之一。他劝说英雄西格德（Sigurd），或者如果你看瓦格纳的话是齐格弗里德（Siegfried），拿着剑去挖一条沟，这条沟沿着法夫纳下来喝水的地方。
And Sigurd lies in this trench. And Fafnir is described as kind of crawling down towards the water. And as he crawls along, Sigurd stabs him in his kind of unprotected underbelly. And Fafnir slowly dies. But as he dies, he talks to Sigurd to try and work out who it is who's killed him, trying to get his name, kind of penetrating his wriggles. He's very, very clever. He's very, very cunning. And when he dies, Sigurd roasts his heart and eats it. And from that point on can understand the language of animals and birds. So there's a lot there that is in the
西格德躺在这条沟里。法夫纳被描述为爬向水边。当他爬行时，西格德刺向他那毫无防备的腹部。法夫纳慢慢地死去。但在他死的时候，他与西格德交谈，试图弄清楚是谁杀了他，试图套出他的名字，试图穿透他的……他非常、非常聪明。他非常、非常狡猾。当他死后，西格德烤了他的心并吃了它。从那一刻起，他就能听懂动物和鸟类的语言。所以《霍比特人》中有很多内容都在这里，对吧？确实有。所以谜语尤其如此。但还有另一个传统。所以北欧文学中第二条重要的龙出现在古英语诗歌《贝奥武夫》中。贝奥武夫是一位伟大的英雄。他对抗三个怪兽。他对抗一个叫格伦德尔（Grendel）的怪兽。他对抗格伦德尔的母亲，在很多方面她甚至更可怕。在他生命的尽头，他对抗这条龙。同样，在这里，龙躺在一大堆宝藏上。一个奴隶来偷了一个金杯。龙立刻注意到了这一点。绝对愤怒，对此火冒三丈。到处烧杀抢掠。所以贝奥武夫渴望保卫他的人民，尽管
Hobbits, right? There is. So the riddles in particular. But there is also another tradition. So the second dragon that is significant in Northern literature appears in the old English poem Beowulf. And Beowulf is a great hero. He confronts three monsters. He confronts a monster called Grendel. He confronts Grendel's mum in lots of ways is even more terrifying. And at the end of his life, he confronts this dragon. And again, in this, the dragon lies on a great pile of treasure. A slave comes and steals a single golden cup. And the dragon immediately notices this. Absolutely furious, livid about it. Goes kind of growing up, burning everyone. And so Be beowulf eager to defend his people despite
他已经很老了，他上去与龙搏斗，他杀死了龙，但他自己也因伤而死。所以汤姆，在那两条龙身上，你拥有了托尔金的龙。所以猜谜——当我们第一次见到史矛革时，他和比尔博玩了这个猜谜游戏，他很聪明，说话很得体之类的。龙守护着被盗的宝藏。我的意思是，那是这两个故事的主题。龙通过腹部的弱点被杀死。所以在《霍比特人》中，他被弓箭手巴德杀死，他被西格德或齐格弗里德（如果你是瓦格纳迷的话）杀死。
being very old goes up and he fights the dragon and he kills the dragon but he himself dies of the wounds so there tom in those two dragons you have you have tolkien's dragon so the riddling so when smough we first meet him he does this riddle game with bilbo and he's clever and he's sort of well-spoken and stuff. The dragon guards stolen treasure. I mean, that's the theme in both of those stories. The dragon is killed by having a vulnerable spot on his underbelly. So in The Hobbit, he's killed by Bard the Bowman, and he's killed by Sigurd or Siegfried, if you're a Wagnerian.
所以托尔金显然是，正如托尔金会做的那样，因为他是牛津大学的英语文学教授，他正在借鉴这些传统。这里显然存在，但在中国龙或《权力的游戏》中不存在的一件事，是宝藏的概念，即龙与某种被盗的宝藏堆有着不可分割的联系。有贪婪。是的，嗯，我认为甚至不止于此，因为法夫纳最初是人类，后来变成了龙，我认为在诺斯和古英语中绝对有一种感觉
So Tolkien obviously is, as Tolkien would, because he was the professor of English literature at Oxford, he's drawing on these traditions. The one thing that obviously is here, but there's not in the Chinese dragons or indeed in Game of Thrones, is the idea of the treasure, that a dragon is inextricably linked to a kind of stolen treasure hoard. There's greed. Yeah, well, I think even more than that because fafnir is originally human and becomes a dragon and i think that there is absolutely a sense in norse and old english
文学中，龙基本上是被贪婪腐蚀的人类。你在各种史诗中一次又一次地看到这一点，那些屈服于贪婪的人，是的，会变成蹲在金堆上的蠕虫状怪兽。在《霍比特人》中，托尔金称之为“龙病”（dragon sickness）。当然，托尔金是 C.S. 路易斯和《纳尼亚传奇》的好朋友。有一个非常相似的情节，尤斯塔斯在《黎明踏浪号》中。他上了一所进步学校。是的，喝了西梅汁，什么都不信。左翼父母。看看你变成了什么样。
literature that dragons are basically humans who have been corrupted by avarice so you see this again and again in various epics that people who who succumb to avarice yeah will turn into a worm-like monster squatting on great piles of gold and in the hobbit tolkien refers to this as dragon sickness and of course tol Tolkien was great friends with C.S. Lewis and the Narnia stories. There is a very similar episode where Eustace in the Dawn Shredder. He went to a progressive school. Yes, and kind of drank prune juice and doesn't believe any of it. Left-wing parents. Look what happens to you.
嗯，他变成了一条龙。是的，可怕的场景。那是他的惩罚。不要去进步学校。你会变成一条龙。这基本上就是那个教训。所以，我的意思是，这显然是一个没有传到《龙之家族》和维斯特洛的传统。但其中一个传下来的事实是，这些是会飞且喷火的怪兽。
Well, he turns into a dragon. Yeah, terrible scenes. That's his punishment. Don't go to progressive schools. You'll turn into a dragon. It's basically the lesson of that. So, I mean, that is obviously a tradition that doesn't pass into House of the Dragon and West West and all that. But one of them that does is the fact that these are monsters that fly and that breathe fire.
所以喷火从很早的时候就存在了，不是吗？当维京人袭击林迪斯法恩时。这是著名的，维京历史中最著名的时刻。他们被视为爆发在欧洲舞台上的时刻。人们谈论闪电和风暴，火龙在空中飞翔。是的。那种火与屠杀的想法，以及在东方聚集的乌云，汤姆，就像它们总是做的那样。是的。那些在诺斯-盎格鲁-撒克逊对龙的理解中都联系在一起，对吧？
So the fire breathing is there from an early point as well, isn't it? So when the Vikings attacked Lindisfarne. This is the famous, famous, most famous moment in kind of Viking history. The moment they're perceived as having erupted onto the European scene. People talk of flashes of lightning and storms and fiery dragons were seen flying in the air. Yeah. And that idea of fire and slaughter and the storm clouds gathering in the east, Tom, as they always do. Yeah. Those are all tied together in that kind of Norse Anglo-Saxon understanding of a dragon, and slaughter and the storm clouds gathering in the east, Tom, as they always do. Those are all tied together in that kind of Norse Anglo-Saxon understanding of a dragon, right?
是的，绝对是。这引发了一个谜题，因为，你知道，我们一直在说龙作为蠕虫的想法在古英语和诺斯文学中是一个非常基础的部分。那么翅膀的想法是从哪里来的呢？因为在诺斯神话中实际上还有另一个著名的龙类怪兽，那就是米德加尔德巨蛇（Midgard Serpent），它是一个绝对巨大的生物，大到它的身体缠绕着地球。在诸神黄昏，末日之时，索尔，那个拿着锤子的神，和米德加尔德巨蛇会互相杀死对方。
Yeah, absolutely. And this raises a kind of a puzzle because, you know, we've been saying that the idea of dragons as worms is a really fundamental part in both Old English and Norse literature. So where is the idea of wings coming from? Because there is actually another famous kind of dragon-esque monster in Norse mythology, which is the Midgard Serpent, which is an absolutely huge creature, which is so enormous that its coils enfold the earth. And at Ragnarok, the end of days, Thor, the god with the hammer, and the Midgard Servant will kind of kill each other.
但没有任何迹象表明米德加尔德巨蛇有腿。法夫纳在去水坑时是爬行的。他似乎并没有在走路。所以他是一条蛇。当然没有飞。我的意思是，他似乎是蠕虫状的。没错。即使在《贝奥武夫》中，虽然龙被描述为有翅膀，
But there's no hint that the Midgard serpent has legs. Fafnir, when he's going down to the waterhole, is crawling. He doesn't seem to be kind of walking. So he's a snake. Certainly not flying. I mean, he seems to be kind of worm-like. Right. And even in Beowulf, although the dragon is described as having wings,
但没有任何迹象表明米德加尔特巨蛇有腿。法夫纳去水坑时是爬行的。他似乎并不是在走路。所以他是一条蛇。当然也不会飞。我的意思是，他看起来有点像蠕虫。没错。即使在《贝奥武夫》中，尽管龙被描述为有翅膀，
he never seems to use them. So I think what you get there is a really strong sense that the tradition of winged dragons is being drafted onto the idea of purely serpentine dragons. So there are two different, that's interesting, there are two different threads then. I think so. That lead to this. So one is your wyrm. Wyrm. And then another is the dragon with wings, which is a different tradition.
他似乎从未使用过它们。所以我认为你在这里得到的是一种非常强烈的意识，即有翼龙的传统被强加到了纯粹的蛇形龙的概念上。所以这里有两种不同的，这很有趣，有两种不同的脉络。我想是这样。导致了这一点。所以一个是你的“wyrm”（无翼龙）。Wyrm。另一个是带翅膀的龙，这是另一个传统。
And in Beowulf, there are two words for dragon. So there is wyrm, but there is also draca and this opens up the question of where is the word draca coming from and i think yeah i mean we will explore this in the second half of this episode that the dragon of westeros is a kind of fusion of the northern dragon the worm and the draca and in the second half we'll see where the drakkar comes from. What drama. Return after the break to find out the true roots of the modern dragon. This episode is brought to you by Sky. Now, Tom, I was chatting to you a couple of days ago, wasn't I? And you said to me just how unbelievably excited you were at the new season of House of the Dragon as the struggle for the Iron Throne descends into death and destruction. Because, Dominic, I actually had the privilege of attending the House of the Dragon season two premiere in the heart of London's glittering West End in Leicester Square.
在《贝奥武夫》中，有两个词指代龙。一个是“wyrm”，但也有“draca”，这就引出了“draca”这个词从何而来的问题。我想，是的，我的意思是，我们将在本集的后半部分探讨这个问题，即维斯特洛的龙是北方龙（wyrm）和“draca”的一种融合，在后半部分我们将看到“drakkar”（维京长船）的由来。多么戏剧性。休息后回来，找出当代龙的真正根源。本集由天空电视台（Sky）赞助播出。那么，汤姆，我几天前和你聊天，对吧？你告诉我，你对《龙之家族》新一季感到多么难以置信的兴奋，因为争夺铁王座的斗争正陷入死亡和毁灭之中。因为，多米尼克，我实际上有幸参加了在伦敦闪耀的西区莱斯特广场举行的《龙之家族》第二季首映式。
And there was a great Iron Throne, which I sat on and posed, I thought, very fetchingly. You were on the red carpet. Incredible scenes. I was treading the red carpet. And I don't want to give any spoilers away, but I can confirm that the desire to make sure of dragon power is basically what both sides are all about. So the blacks, they have more dragons,
那里有一个巨大的铁王座，我坐在上面摆了姿势，我想，姿势非常迷人。你在红地毯上。不可思议的场景。我走在红地毯上。我不想剧透，但我可以确认，确保龙的力量的渴望基本上就是双方争斗的全部意义所在。所以黑党，他们有更多的龙，
but the problem is the greens have the most formidable dragon of all, the world's largest dragon, Vhagar. So it's all about air power. So Tom, with the realm divided, all the Westeros must choose a side. Would you pledge your allegiance, Tom, to the greens or to the blacks? Dominic, obviously the greens are usurpers, so I wouldn't pledge my allegiance to them. I pledge my sword to the blacks of House Targaryen, and the fact that they have more dragons is nothing to do with it. But Tom, of course, the counter-argument would be that Vhagar is a lot bigger than the
但问题是绿党拥有最强大的龙，世界上体型最大的龙，瓦格哈尔（Vhagar）。所以这完全是关于空中力量。那么汤姆，随着王国分裂，整个维斯特洛都必须选择立场。汤姆，你会向绿党还是黑党宣誓效忠？多米尼克，显然绿党是篡位者，所以我不会向他们宣誓效忠。我向坦格利安家族的黑党献上我的剑，他们拥有更多的龙与此无关。但是汤姆，当然，反驳的观点是瓦格哈尔比
blacks' largest dragon. So are you siding, as so often in your career, with the minnows, with the underdogs? No, I'm siding with the side that has right on its side, but also has lots of dragons, and also has the backing of Westeros's greatest fleet led by Corlys Velaryon the Sea Snake. And he's an absolutely tremendous chap and very much the kind of person that you would want on side. And Dominic, you know, having done episodes on the Battle of Trafalgar with me, that I'm
黑党最大的龙要大得多。所以，像你职业生涯中经常做的那样，你是站在弱者、失败者一边吗？不，我站在正义的一边，但也拥有大量的龙，并且还拥有由“海蛇”科利斯·瓦列利安领导的维斯特洛最伟大的舰队的支持。他是一个绝对了不起的人，非常适合你想要拉拢的那种人。多米尼克，你知道，和我一起做过关于特拉法尔加海战的节目，你知道我
a great enthusiast for naval power. Well, Tom, that absolutely settles it, doesn't it? So House of the Dragon is available now exclusively on Sky, with new episodes every Monday. Please go to sky.com to find out more. As the serpent coiled, so Medea approached it. In a sweet voice, she invoked sleep, highest of the gods, to help her. Jason followed her, terrified. But the monster was already bewitched by her song and had begun to unfold its long, spiraling spine and straighten its countless circles, just as a black wave, silent and without noise, rolls over a calm sea. Even so, it raised its terrible head aloft and was eager to enfold a pair of them in its ruinous jaws.
是一个海军力量的狂热爱好者。好吧，汤姆，这绝对解决了问题，不是吗？所以《龙之家族》现在在天空电视台独家播出，每周一更新。请访问sky.com了解更多信息。当蛇盘绕时，美狄亚靠近了它。她用甜美的声音祈求众神之首——睡神来帮助她。伊阿宋惊恐地跟在她身后。但怪物已经被她的歌声迷住了，开始展开它长长的、螺旋状的脊椎，拉直它无数的圆圈，就像一道黑色波浪，静默无声地滚过平静的海面。即便如此，它还是高高抬起那可怕的头，渴望用它那毁灭性的下颚将他们两人吞没。
But Medea sprinkled its eyes with a fresh-cut spring of juniper, dipping it into her potion to the accompaniment of her incantations. The snake dropped its jaw and rested it just where it was. Its endless coils were unfurled far behind it through the wood of many trees. Then, as the girl instructed him, Jason reached for the golden fleece from the oak and took it. So that, Tom, was Apollonius. Not Ian McKellen.
但美狄亚用一根刚折下的杜松树枝蘸着她的药水，伴随着咒语洒在它的眼睛上。蛇张开下颚，停在了原地。它无尽的盘绕在它身后的树林中展开。然后，按照女孩的指示，伊阿宋从橡树上取下了金羊毛。所以，汤姆，那是阿波罗尼奥斯。不是伊恩·麦克莱恩。
Well, it was Apollonius, actually. It was Ian McKellen. We're very grateful to Sir Ian for joining us on the show and reading it in the voice of Gandalf. I thought it was Tolkien again. Yeah, well, that's the thing. It's done it in identical voices. Well, they are identical voices. Ian McKellen's Gandalf and Tolkien. I thought it was Tolkien again. Yeah, well, that's the thing. It's done it in identical voices. Well, they are identical voices.
嗯，其实是阿波罗尼奥斯。是伊恩·麦克莱恩。我们非常感谢伊恩爵士加入我们的节目，并用甘道夫的声音朗读了这段文字。我还以为又是托尔金呢。是的，嗯，就是这样。它用完全相同的声音完成了。嗯，它们确实是相同的声音。伊恩·麦克莱恩的甘道夫和托尔金。我还以为又是托尔金呢。是的，嗯，就是这样。它用完全相同的声音完成了。嗯，它们确实是相同的声音。
In MacKellan's Gandalf and Tolkien, I think sound very similar. And that's how Apollonius sounded. Well, who knew? So that's from the third century BC, Tom, as you will know. And Apollonius is describing that crucial moment in the story of Jason and the Argonauts when Medea, the sort of witch queen, has bewitched this serpent. Jason goes and gets the golden fleece. So Jason and the Argonauts, one of the great Greek myths. Jason and all his pals, Heracles, all the lads. They've gone off across the Black Sea to Colchis. They've got the golden fleece.
伊恩·麦克莱恩的甘道夫和托尔金，我觉得听起来非常相似。这就是阿波罗尼奥斯听起来的样子。好吧，谁知道呢？所以那是公元前三世纪的作品，汤姆，正如你所知。阿波罗尼奥斯描述了伊阿宋和阿尔戈英雄故事中那个关键时刻，当时美狄亚，那位女巫女王，已经迷住了这条蛇。伊阿宋去拿到了金羊毛。所以伊阿宋和阿尔戈英雄，伟大的希腊神话之一。伊阿宋和他的伙伴们，赫拉克勒斯，所有的小伙子们。他们横渡黑海前往科尔基斯。他们拿到了金羊毛。
Great scenes. Some darkness to come. Some darkness to come, yes. We don't need to get into that now. Little boys being chopped up and thrown into the sea. But I mean, it's an example of a snake that isn't kind of lying around licking saws and being nice. No, it's a malevolent snake.
伟大的场景。还有一些黑暗即将到来。是的，还有一些黑暗即将到来。我们现在不需要讨论那个。小男孩被切碎扔进海里。但我的意思是，这是一个不是躺着舔锯子、表现友好的蛇的例子。不，这是一条恶毒的蛇。
It's a malevolent, terrifying monster. And there are a lot of these kind of serpentine monsters in Greek myth. So there's the python, which Apollo shoots. It had been occupying the site of Delphi, so this is where Apollo's great oracle will be. And also there's the hydra, which is the multi-headed monster that Heracles kills for his second labor. And the Greek word for these serpentine monsters is dracone.
这是一个恶毒、可怕的怪物。希腊神话中有很多这种蛇形怪物。比如阿波罗射杀的皮同（Python）。它一直占据着德尔斐的遗址，所以这就是阿波罗伟大的神谕所在地。还有九头蛇（Hydra），那是赫拉克勒斯为了完成他的第二个任务而杀死的那个多头怪物。希腊语中这些蛇形怪物的词是“dracone”。
And a dracone is different from an office, which is just a snake. And there's a wonderful book by a scholar called Daniel Ogden called The Dragon in the West that zooms in on what is a dracone. And he basically says that a dracone is a snake and something more. So a hydra would be a dracone and not a snake because it's got loads of heads, that kind of thing. And also, so the dracone is often portrayed on vases where he's shown with a beard, which is nice.
“dracone”与“ophis”不同，后者只是一条蛇。有一位名叫丹尼尔·奥格登的学者写了一本精彩的书，名为《西方的龙》，书中聚焦于什么是“dracone”。他基本上说“dracone”是一条蛇，但不仅仅是蛇。所以九头蛇会是一个“dracone”而不是一条蛇，因为它有很多头，诸如此类。而且，所以“dracone”经常被描绘在花瓶上，在那里它被画成留着胡子，这很有趣。
So it seems to come from Egypt. You do kind of get bearded creatures. No, you don't get bearded snakes though. Like a bearded, like a schnauzer, like a dog? No. No, because these are kind of like the beards that, you know, pharaohs have, kind of long, long thin ones. And Ogden in his book, he kind of lists all the various elements
所以它似乎来自埃及。你确实会得到留着胡子的生物。不，你不会得到留着胡子的蛇。像留着胡子，像雪纳瑞，像狗一样？不。不，因为这些就像法老们留的那种胡子，那种又长又细的。奥格登在他的书中，他列出了所有各种元素
that characterize these stories of draconis coming out um it lives in a cave yeah it will often kind of monopolize a water source so the hydra for instance lives in a you know in a swamp yeah the python inhabits a spring it's always marauding around so it's kind of nicking cattle and burning crops and all that kind of thing it's fiery and poisonous and kind of clouds of pestilence hang over it but no treasure in this right so that's a big difference so the treasure seems to be a kind of um a northern a product of the northern world and the and the worm but a dracon is more sort of pestilential water-based yeah eating oxen yeah that kind of thing.
这些关于“draconis”出现的传说特征，嗯，它住在洞穴里，是的，它通常会垄断水源，所以九头蛇例如住在沼泽里，是的，皮同居住在泉水里，它总是四处掠夺，所以它会偷牛、烧毁庄稼等等。它火热且有毒，瘟疫的云雾笼罩着它，但没有宝藏，对吧？所以这是一个很大的区别，所以宝藏似乎是北方世界和“wyrm”的一种产物，但“dracon”更多是瘟疫般的、基于水的，是的，吃牛，诸如此类。
Also doesn't have wings and doesn't have legs. So how are these kind of Greek draconis, if these are also part of the ancestry, what is going on? And the first thing to say is that these myths are massively, massively influential. So everyone in the Greek world knows them. And of course, then under the in the Greek world knows them. And of course, then under the Romans, everyone basically knows them. And the Romans love these kind of stories of dracontes, you know, dragons, let's call them dragons, because draco in Latin is the word from which dragon comes. And they even tell stories themselves. So there's a very, very Roman dragon story where Regulus, people who listened to our episode on the first
也没有翅膀，也没有腿。那么这些希腊的“draconis”如果也是祖先的一部分，到底是怎么回事？首先要说的是，这些神话的影响力非常、非常大。所以希腊世界的每个人都知道它们。当然，在罗马人统治下，每个人基本上也都知道它们。罗马人喜欢这些关于“dracontes”的故事，你知道，龙，让我们称它们为龙，因为拉丁语中的“draco”就是“dragon”一词的来源。他们甚至自己讲述故事。所以有一个非常、非常罗马的龙的故事，雷古勒斯，听过我们关于第一次布匿战争那一集的人，
Punic War, Regulus is a consul who leads an invasion of Africa fighting against the Carthaginians. And they come up against a draco. So a terrible fire flashed forth from its twin eyes. The height of its raised crest exceeded that of the grove and the high treetops of the wood. Its tongue flickered and flashed through the air. And I think it's very Roman that rather than sending out a champion to fight it, which is obviously what would happen in a Greek myth or a kind of medieval romance, they break off their catapults and batter it to death with stones. That is very Roman. Very, very Roman. But the Romans, I think they kind of really like the Draco. So in their stories, the Draco invariably has kind of character, is an individual, often
雷古勒斯是一位领兵入侵非洲对抗迦太基人的执政官。他们遇到了一个“draco”。所以可怕的火焰从它那双眼睛中闪烁而出。它高耸的冠冕高度超过了树林和高大的树梢。它的舌头在空中闪烁。我认为这非常罗马，与其派出一个冠军去战斗，这显然是希腊神话或中世纪浪漫故事中会发生的事情，他们拆掉弹射器，用石头把它砸死。这非常罗马。非常、非常罗马。但罗马人，我认为他们真的很喜欢“Draco”。所以在他们的故事中，“Draco”总是有一种性格，是一个个体，通常
has a certain sense of dignity. So that's something that the Romans add to the mix. And because they are so keen on the figure of the Draco, they're always putting them into bars, into mosaics, paintings, putting them into their poetry. And over the course of time, you get kind of various other elements that join the mix. So we've talked about sea monsters, you know, the sea monster that Scourus brought from Joppa that's supposed to have been turned to stone by Perseus. And sea monsters can be like snakes, but they can also kind of be like whales. And whales have flippers.
有一种尊严感。所以这是罗马人加入其中的东西。因为他们非常热衷于“Draco”的形象，他们总是把它们放进花瓶、马赛克、绘画中，放进他们的诗歌中。随着时间的推移，你会得到各种其他元素加入其中。我们谈到了海怪，你知道，斯考鲁斯从约帕带来的海怪，据说被珀尔修斯变成了石头。海怪可以像蛇，但也可以像鲸鱼。鲸鱼有鳍。
And so over the course of the history of the Roman Empire, you start to get dragons with kind of flippers, which then start to kind of become legs. So basically you're saying that Roman interior decorators create the idea of the legged dragon. I mean, what they're doing. So you think about the wall paintings you get in Pompeii, for instance. They like monsters. And you have the draco and you have the sea monster. And if the sea monster can be a whale, then you can give it flippers or give it legs.
所以在罗马帝国历史的过程中，你开始得到有鳍的龙，然后开始变成腿。所以你基本上是说罗马的室内装饰师创造了有腿龙的概念。我的意思是，他们正在做的事情。所以你想想庞贝古城的壁画，例如。他们喜欢怪物。你有“draco”，你有海怪。如果海怪可以是鲸鱼，那么你可以给它鳍或给它腿。
Yeah, I wouldn't give a whale legs. And if you want to, you could give it wings, perhaps, or whatever. But I don't think that the interior decoration of robert living rooms is where the wings come from okay because dominic it will thrill you to know oh no that i think that the wings are derived from christianity i knew this would i feared i genuinely dreaded that this would this would be the case. So obviously there are kind of dragon-ish creatures in Greek mythology, but there are also a lot in the Bible. So I was wondering why you didn't mention the,
是的，我不会给鲸鱼腿。如果你愿意，你可以给它翅膀，也许，或者其他什么。但我不认为罗伯特客厅的室内装饰是翅膀的来源，好吧，因为多米尼克，你会很高兴知道，哦不，我认为翅膀源于基督教，我知道这会，我担心，我真的害怕这会是这种情况。所以显然希腊神话中有一些龙一样的生物，但圣经中也有很多。所以我很好奇为什么你没有提到，
why you hadn't mentioned the serpent in the Garden of Eden. I'm guessing because you're going to now. So that's not a worm. I mean, that could be very worm-like, isn't it? Well, it does sort of make elliptical obscure references. It's kind of seductive, like these kind of like smaugers. Yeah. And in rabbinical traditions, which you don't actually get in Genesis, there are accounts that the serpent in the Garden of Eden had legs and part of its punishment when it has to kind of crawl on the ground and dust, the legs go. So there's something
为什么你没有提到伊甸园里的蛇。我猜是因为你现在要说了。所以那不是“wyrm”。我的意思是，那可能非常像“wyrm”，不是吗？嗯，它确实会做出一些椭圆形的模糊引用。它有点诱人，就像这些像史矛革一样的生物。是的。在拉比传统中，你在《创世记》中实际上没有得到，有记载说伊甸园里的蛇有腿，当它不得不爬在地上和尘土中时，它的惩罚的一部分就是腿没了。所以那里有一些
there. But I think an even kind of more menacing dragon-ish figure in the Bible is the figure of Leviathan, which is a kind of giant monster that clearly in the traditions from which the biblical traditions are deriving, the figure of God is fighting the Leviathan. And those traditions, they have a ghostly presence in the biblical texts. And in Revelation, in the book of revelation is there not a dragon there is a dragon and i think that that portrait of the dragon is definitely drawing on the figure of leviathan so there's a kind of brilliant account of leviathan in the book of job where god appears and basically kind of tells job off for moaning yeah and this is god describing leviathan out of
东西。但我认为圣经中一个更具威胁性的龙一样的形象是利维坦（Leviathan），它是一种巨大的怪物，显然在圣经传统所源于的传统中，上帝的形象正在与利维坦战斗。而这些传统在圣经文本中有一种幽灵般的存在。在《启示录》中，难道没有龙吗？有一条龙，我认为那个龙的画像绝对借鉴了利维坦的形象，所以《约伯记》中有一段关于利维坦的精彩描述，上帝出现并基本上责备约伯抱怨，是的，这就是上帝描述利维坦，从
his mouth go burning lamps and sparks of fire leap out. Out of his nostrils goeth smoke as out of a seething pot or cauldron. His breath kindleth coals and a flame goeth out of his mouth. God would have had a voice of Ian McKellen there. Well, all right. Maybe you should have read that. But as you say, this is then an influence on a book in the New Testament, which is clearly drawing on all these traditions. And in the book of Revelation, there is a vision of the future that is to come.
他的嘴里喷出燃烧的灯火和火花。从他的鼻孔里冒出烟雾，就像从沸腾的锅或大锅里冒出来一样。他的呼吸点燃煤炭，火焰从他口中喷出。上帝会有伊恩·麦克莱恩的声音。好吧，好吧。也许你应该读那个。但正如你所说，这随后对新约中的一本书产生了影响，该书显然借鉴了所有这些传统。在《启示录》中，有一个关于未来的愿景。
And there are quite a lot of kind of dragon-like monsters in it. And the most sinister, the most sinister dracon is a red dracon. It has seven heads, 10 horns, each is crowned with a diadem. And this is the very embodiment of evil. So famous passage. And there was war in heaven. Michael, who is the captain of heaven, the great archangel, and his angels fought against the dragon and the dragon fought and his angels and prevailed not. Neither was their place found anymore in heaven. And the great dragon was cast out, that old serpent called the devil and Satan, which deceiveth the whole world. He was cast out into the earth and his angels were cast out with him. And I think that this is the crucial development for fans of dragon wings,
里面有很多龙一样的怪物。最险恶、最险恶的“dracon”是一条红色的“dracon”。它有七个头，十个角，每个角都戴着王冠。这就是邪恶的化身。所以著名的段落。天上发生了战争。米迦勒，天上的统帅，伟大的大天使，和他的天使与龙争战，龙和他的天使也争战，并没有得胜。天上再也没有他们的地方了。大龙被摔倒，那条古蛇，名叫魔鬼，又叫撒旦，是迷惑普天下的。他被摔在地上，他的天使也一同被摔下去。我认为这对龙翼的粉丝来说是一个关键的发展，
because this is directly identifying the figure of the draco, the dragon, with the demonic. And demons, according to Christian tradition, right from the beginning, have wings. So that's in the Book of Revelation. In the centuries that follow, so we're in the time of the Roman Empire, and people believe that demons exist, don't they? I mean, there's references to church fathers and so on.
因为这直接将“draco”、龙的形象与恶魔联系起来。根据基督教传统，恶魔从一开始就有翅膀。所以这在《启示录》中。在随后的几个世纪里，所以我们处于罗马帝国时期，人们相信恶魔存在，不是吗？我的意思是，有关于教会神父等的参考。
And that they have wings. And that they have wings. And that they think demons have the form of serpents or dragons. And that must be also clearly reflecting the fact that they are dealing with a tradition in which the fount of all evil is the serpent in the Garden of Eden. So it must be reptilian. But so the church fathers are obviously drawing on the biblical traditions. They're drawing on the tradition that demons have wings.
而且他们有翅膀。而且他们有翅膀。而且他们认为恶魔有蛇或龙的形式。这一定也清楚地反映了这样一个事实，即他们正在处理一个传统，在这个传统中，所有邪恶的源头是伊甸园里的蛇。所以它必须是爬行动物。但是，所以教会神父显然借鉴了圣经传统。他们借鉴了恶魔有翅膀的传统。
But they are also, of course, living in the Roman Empire. So they have all these traditions about draconis as well. So Augustine, who's writing in Latin at the beginning of the fifth century AD, he's writing about draconis and he says that they live in the region of water, which is obviously- Oh, from the Greek myths. Yeah. I mean, that's coming from Greek tradition. They come forth from caves. Again, that's very much in the Greek tradition and they launch themselves into the air. This is the Christian contribution to the figure of the Draco. The air is this for sure, but I think we can be reasonably sure that Augustine never actually saw a dragon. I think we can be relatively sure of that, yeah.
但他们当然也生活在罗马帝国。所以他们也有所有关于“draconis”的传统。所以奥古斯丁，他在公元五世纪初用拉丁语写作，他写到了“draconis”，他说它们生活在水的区域，这显然是——哦，来自希腊神话。是的。我的意思是，那来自希腊传统。它们从洞穴中出来。同样，这非常符合希腊传统，它们把自己发射到空中。这是基督教对“Draco”形象的贡献。空气肯定是这样，但我认为我们可以相当肯定奥古斯丁从未真正见过龙。我想我们可以相对肯定这一点，是的。
But does he believe that they physically, literally exist? Yes, I think he does. And where does he think they are? I think that that is a kind of possibly overly 21st century question. I think he thinks that they live in the dimension of the infernal. So they're in hell. But when they appear in dreams and visions, they are not fantasies. He doesn't think there's like a cave in modern day Tunisia where there's plausibly a dragon. Well, I don't know about Augustine himself, but there are definitely lots of traditions in which saints confront dragons.
但他是否认为它们在物理上、字面上存在？是的，我想他是。他认为它们在哪里？我认为这是一个可能过于21世纪的问题。我认为他认为它们生活在地狱的维度。所以它们在地狱里。但当它们出现在梦境和幻象中时，它们不是幻想。他不认为现代突尼斯有一个洞穴，那里可能有一条龙。嗯，我不知道奥古斯丁本人，但肯定有很多圣徒对抗龙的传统。
And I think that people absolutely believe in these. And also that saints can have visions of dragons that are completely authentic. So around the time that Augustine is writing, there's a Greek text that describes St. Bartholomew, who's one of Christ's disciples, one of the apostles. He's with Jesus and he can ask Jesus anything he wants. And so he does what I think I would do, which is to say, you know, I'd love to see the dragon that will fight with St. Michael at the end of days. That would be a one-way. I'd quite like to see a to say, you know, I'd love to see the dragon that will fight with St. Michael at the end of days. That would be a one-way.
我认为人们绝对相信这些。而且圣徒也可以有完全真实的龙的幻象。所以在大约奥古斯丁写作的时候，有一篇希腊文本描述了圣巴塞洛缪，他是基督的门徒之一，使徒之一。他和耶稣在一起，他可以问耶稣任何他想问的问题。所以他做了我想我会做的事，那就是说，你知道，我很想看到那条将在末日与圣米迦勒战斗的龙。那将是单向的。我很想看到一个，说，你知道，我很想看到那条将在末日与圣米迦勒战斗的龙。那将是单向的。
I'd quite like to see a dragon. Okay. And Jesus says, I don't think you should see it. I think it's too frightening. And St. Bartholomew says, go on. So Jesus says, fine. And so St. Bartholomew sees the greatest of all dragons, that is Satan, the old serpent. And the dragon is bound in chains of fire.
我很想看到一条龙。好吧。耶稣说，我不认为你应该看到它。我认为它太可怕了。圣巴塞洛缪说，继续吧。所以耶稣说，好吧。于是圣巴塞洛缪看到了所有龙中最伟大的一条，那就是撒旦，那条古蛇。龙被火链束缚着。
It has a face like a lightning bolt. Very sinister. Foul-smelling smoke is drifting from its nostrils. Lightning bolt-shaped nostrils. Yeah, exactly. It is enormous. And it has one wing, which is a very weird detail. I find that the most sinister and unsettling of all those details.
它有一张像闪电一样的脸。非常险恶。恶臭的烟雾从它的鼻孔中飘出。闪电形状的鼻孔。是的，完全正确。它非常巨大。它有一只翅膀，这是一个非常奇怪的细节。我发现这是所有细节中最险恶和令人不安的。
So it's like kind of a helicopter. I mean, I don't quite know how it works. Yeah. A one-winged dragon. I actually find such a troubling thought. Yeah. So Augustine is writing at a time when the West and the eastern halves of the empire are still part of a single geopolitical entity.
所以它有点像直升机。我的意思是，我不太清楚它是怎么运作的。是的。一只翅膀的龙。我实际上发现这是一个非常令人不安的想法。是的。所以奥古斯丁写作的时候，帝国的西部和东部仍然是单一地缘政治实体的一部分。
But obviously, over the centuries that follow, the West very much goes on a kind of separate route from the Eastern half because it's been conquered by incoming barbarian warlords and whatnot. And new kingdoms emerge on the rubble of what had been the Roman Empire. And so the traditions of the dragon become very specifically Latin, very specifically Western, although there are kind of influences coming from the Greek world. So by AD 800, which is the year that Charlemagne is being crowned emperor in Rome. But also right about the time that the fiery dragons are appearing above Lindisfarne. Yes, absolutely so. And Alcuin, who is Charlemagne's great advisor, is a Northumbrian and is terribly upset that
但显然，在随后的几个世纪里，西部与东部走了一条完全不同的路线，因为它被入侵的野蛮军阀等征服了。新的王国在罗马帝国的废墟上崛起。因此，龙的传统变得非常具体地拉丁化，非常具体地西方化，尽管有来自希腊世界的影响。所以到了公元800年，也就是查理曼大帝在罗马加冕为皇帝的那一年。但也就在火龙出现在林迪斯法恩上空的时候。是的，绝对是这样。阿尔昆，查理曼大帝的伟大顾问，是诺森布里亚人，他对
Lindisfarne has been sacked. So he's aware of these dragons. Around this time, you are getting a manuscript of Revelation, which includes eight pictures of a Draco. And it's serpentine, so it hasn't got any legs, but it does have wings. So this is the first portrayal of a dragon that you can say, yeah, it has wings. It's an obvious, it's a modern dragon. And by the end of the ninth century, you are starting to get illustrations of kind of serpentine reptilian creatures with wings, with legs that are breathing fire. You know, these are clearly dragons of the kind that you get in the house of the dragon. So at this point, you have got the union of maybe three different traditions.
林迪斯法恩被洗劫感到非常难过。所以他知道这些龙。大约在这个时候，你得到了一份《启示录》的手稿，其中包括八幅“Draco”的图片。它是蛇形的，所以它没有腿，但它确实有翅膀。所以这是第一幅你可以说“是的，它有翅膀”的龙的画像。这是一条现代的龙。到了九世纪末，你开始得到那种有翅膀、有腿、喷火的蛇形爬行动物插图。你知道，这些显然是你在《龙之家族》中得到的那种龙。所以此时，你已经融合了三种不同的传统。
Greco-Roman, the kind of classical, then you've got your biblical demonic dragon, as it were, and then you've got the Norse, the idea of the dragon with his treasure, sort of incarnation of greed, all of that kind of thing. So you're listening to me and wondering, well, how does this Greco-Roman Christian figure of the dragon, the Draco, merge with the worm that we get in, say, Beowulf. And I think it's because for the Vikings, the Christian world, although it's something to
希腊-罗马，那种古典的，然后你有你的圣经恶魔龙，可以说，然后你有北欧的，龙带着宝藏的想法，贪婪的化身，所有这些东西。所以你在听我说话，想知道，这种希腊-罗马基督教的龙形象，“Draco”，是如何与我们在《贝奥武夫》中得到的“wyrm”融合的。我认为这是因为对于维京人来说，基督教世界，尽管它是某种
prey on, is also something that is a kind of wellspring of prestige and authority, which is why over the course of the Viking age, the Viking kings and then the Vikings themselves start to convert to Christianity. And I think that the Latin dragon, it's a marker of prestige. It's the kind, you know, if you have a dragon, you want it to have wings because that's the kind of the cutting edge. We could get really bogged down in this so we can save this for another podcast. But Beowulf itself, there are a lot of scholars who would argue that Beowulf itself is a fusion of Norse and Christian traditions.
掠夺的对象，也是一种声望和权威的源泉，这就是为什么在维京时代，维京国王然后维京人自己开始皈依基督教。我认为拉丁龙，它是声望的标志。它是那种，你知道，如果你有一条龙，你会希望它有翅膀，因为那是前沿的东西。我们可能会陷入其中，所以我们可以把这个留到另一个播客中。但《贝奥武夫》本身，有很多学者会争辩说《贝奥武夫》本身是北欧和基督教传统的融合。
And so the dragon may be in Beowulf, is a fusion of Norse and Christian traditions. And so the dragon may be in Beowulf, may be slightly imported. Yeah. So the date of Beowulf is much contested, but I think it's entirely possible that the tradition of the worm, the tradition of the Draco, the way in which even though the dragon in Beowulf has wings, but can't fly, what you're seeing is a kind of writer in Old English wanting to give it a bit of kind of sophisticated Latin garnishing. And so the thing is that the dragon, say, around the time of the millennium in Latin Europe, is not seen as something primordial. I mean, it's only been around for maybe a century. It's seen as very, very cutting edge. And there are
所以龙可能在《贝奥武夫》中，是北欧和基督教传统的融合。所以龙可能在《贝奥武夫》中，可能是稍微进口的。是的。所以《贝奥武夫》的日期争议很大，但我认为完全有可能的是，“wyrm”的传统，“Draco”的传统，尽管《贝奥武夫》中的龙有翅膀但不能飞，你所看到的是一位古英语作家想要给它一点复杂的拉丁装饰。所以事情是这样的，龙，大约在拉丁欧洲的千年左右，并不被视为原始的东西。我的意思是，它只存在了大约一个世纪。它被视为非常、非常前沿。而且有
a lot of dragons that are recorded in chronicles of this age. The previous episode that went out, we were talking about Theophanu, the mother of the emperor Otto III, who rules at the time of the millennium. And he dies, but his death is presaged by the sight of a massive dragon flying overhead. And often these descriptions are incredibly matter of fact. So there's a wonderful one recorded by a monk who is crossing the Hungarian plain. And he says, you know, that there was this dragon, it was flying overhead. Its plumed head was the height of a mountain. Its body was covered with scales like shields of iron. And he's recording it as,
很多龙被记录在这个时代的编年史中。上一集播出的节目中，我们谈到了奥托三世皇帝的母亲狄奥法诺，他在千年之交统治。他去世了，但他的死被头顶飞过的一条巨大龙的景象所预示。通常这些描述非常客观。所以有一位僧侣记录了一个精彩的描述，他正在穿越匈牙利平原。他说，你知道，有这条龙，它在头顶飞过。它羽毛状的头有山那么高。它的身体覆盖着像铁盾一样的鳞片。他记录它为，
you know, as you might, I saw an interesting cow or, you know, there was a kind of interesting storm or something. And I think that it's the fusion of the matter of fact and the apocalyptic because this is the millennial age. Loads of pilgrims are crossing the plain of Hungary to go to Jerusalem in this period. And thoughts of dragons, of Satan, of the kind of confrontation at the end of the world is absolutely part of that. They are blinded, Tom, by their own religious enthusiasm. Well, you might say that, or you might say... They've genuinely seen a dragon. You might say that. I mean, that's certainly what I think Tolkien would say.
你知道，就像你可能说的那样，我看到了一头有趣的牛，或者，你知道，有一场有趣的暴风雨之类的。我认为这是客观和末日论的融合，因为这是千年时代。在这个时期，大量的朝圣者穿越匈牙利平原前往耶路撒冷。关于龙、撒旦、世界末日对抗的想法绝对是其中的一部分。他们被自己的宗教热情蒙蔽了，汤姆。好吧，你可能会那样说，或者你可能会说……他们真的看到了龙。你可能会那样说。我的意思是，这绝对是我认为托尔金会说的。
They don't have four legs, these dragons that they... No. So these are what heralds in Britain and Ireland would call a wyvern. Right. So the distinction is made by basically British heralds. And why the idea of that comes from a viper, right? So it's more serpentine. It's more serpentine. It only has two legs.
这些龙没有四条腿，它们……不。所以这些是英国和爱尔兰的纹章官所说的“双足飞龙”（wyvern）。对。所以这种区别基本上是由英国纹章官做出的。为什么这个想法来自毒蛇，对吧？所以它更像蛇。它更像蛇。它只有两条腿。
But in the rest of Europe, there's no distinction. They're all dragons. And so people may be wondering, well, the last kind of piece of the jigsaw is how these two-legged creatures, the wyverns, become four-legged. And I suppose it's probably because people are kind of thinking if they've got two legs, maybe they're more like lizards than snakes. And so giving them four legs is kind of obvious. But again, it takes a long time for this to happen. So there is one, there's a manuscript in Ghent in the 12th century that I think is the first show of four-legged dragon.
但在欧洲其他地方，没有区别。它们都是龙。所以人们可能想知道，拼图的最后一块是这些两条腿的生物，双足飞龙，是如何变成四条腿的。我想这可能是因为人们在想，如果它们有两条腿，也许它们更像蜥蜴而不是蛇。所以给它们四条腿是很明显的。但同样，这需要很长时间才能发生。所以有一个，根特有一份12世纪的手稿，我认为是第一幅四条腿龙的展示。
But the image of dragons having four legs is really late 14th century and particularly 15th century. You know, this is the dragon-like smile that you get. Yeah. And I think that the reason why this image gets imprinted for centuries and centuries to come is because, of course, this is the age of printing. So printed book, the first printed books have dragons in them because people love dragons. They're the canonical monster of the time. And they have the four legs, the wings, the lidless reptilian face, breathing fire, I guess, Tom.
但龙有四条腿的形象确实是14世纪末，特别是15世纪。你知道，这就是你得到的龙一样的微笑。是的。我认为这个形象被印刻了几个世纪的原因是，当然，这是印刷时代。所以印刷书籍，第一批印刷书籍里有龙，因为人们喜欢龙。它们是那个时代典型的怪物。它们有四条腿、翅膀、无眼睑的爬行动物脸，喷火，我想，汤姆。
But is it not also that people in England in particular are very excited about dragons because, of course, the dragon is the symbol of the Tudors. Henry Tudor wins Battle of Bosworth. The idea of the red dragon and the white and the union of, you know, all of that stuff. So dragons start appearing on flags and start appearing on, you know, the royal coats of arms.
但难道不是因为英国人特别对龙感到兴奋吗，因为当然，龙是都铎王朝的象征。亨利·都铎赢得了博斯沃思战役。红龙和白龙的想法以及所有这些东西的结合。所以龙开始出现在旗帜上，开始出现在皇家纹章上。
So that also kind of beds it down. So you take someone like Henry VIII. Henry VIII is obsessed with heraldry. He loves tournaments. He loves the romance of Arthur, all of that kind of thing. And in his iconography, I guess, the dragon, that's a really important part to play. And so I think that this is why the combination of printing, the fact that you're starting to get books now, say Mallory, Thomas Mallory writing about King Arthur. You're getting Tudor heraldry. I think that that's why the backdrop to dragon stories tends to be 15th century and early 16th century. And I think this is the genius of House of the Dragon, and in fact, Game of Thrones as well, is that when we did
所以这也把它固定下来了。所以你看看像亨利八世这样的人。亨利八世痴迷于纹章学。他喜欢锦标赛。他喜欢亚瑟王的浪漫，所有这些东西。在他的肖像画中，我想，龙，这是一个非常重要的部分。所以我认为这就是为什么印刷术的结合，你现在开始有书的事实，比如马洛里，托马斯·马洛里写关于亚瑟王。你正在得到都铎纹章。我认为这就是为什么龙故事的背景往往是15世纪和16世纪初。我认为这就是《龙之家族》的天才之处，事实上《权力的游戏》也是如此，当我们做
our episode on Game of Thrones ages ago, one of the points we made was that King's Landing, the center of action, is 15th century. And in the House of the Dragon and in Game of Thrones, there is definitely a kind of War of the Roses element, which is the great dynastic struggle of the 15th century. So in the first series of the House of the Dragon, you have tournaments in very 15th century armor. You have kind of a Mallory-esque quest for a white heart. You have a Richard III figure who's kind of, you know, wears black and is lame and is scheming and plotting in the background. And you have a feud between an elder sister and a kind of younger sibling,
我们很久以前关于《权力的游戏》的那一集时，我们提出的观点之一是，国王登陆，行动的中心，是15世纪。在《龙之家族》和《权力的游戏》中，绝对有一种玫瑰战争的元素，这是15世纪伟大的王朝斗争。所以在《龙之家族》的第一系列中，你有非常15世纪盔甲的锦标赛。你有某种马洛里式的寻找白鹿的任务。你有一个理查三世式的人物，他，你知道，穿着黑色，跛脚，在背景中策划和阴谋。你有一个姐姐和弟弟之间的世仇，
very reminiscent of the reign of Henry VIII. And I think that it's that that makes the dragons so appropriate to the setting. And isn't that interesting, Tom, because probably some of that is unconscious, right? That it's actually just a buried association. Yeah, maybe. I'm sure not all of it is unconscious, but when we think of dragons and knights, we think of them in their sort of slightly decadent 15th century, very fancy armor. We don't think of Beowulf. We don't think of 10th, 11th century or something. It means that in a weird way, even though it's a 21st century creation, it is true to the foundational principles of dragonology, if that's what.
非常让人想起亨利八世的统治。我认为正是这一点使得龙与背景如此相称。这难道不有趣吗，汤姆，因为其中一些可能是无意识的，对吧？它实际上只是一个埋藏的联想。是的，也许。我肯定不是所有的都是无意识的，但当我们想到龙和骑士时，我们会想到他们那种稍微颓废的15世纪、非常华丽的盔甲。我们不会想到《贝奥武夫》。我们不会想到10世纪、11世纪之类的。这意味着以一种奇怪的方式，尽管它是21世纪的创造，但它忠实于龙学的基础原则，如果那是的话。
I would like to think that there is. And I think also, we talked about how printing kind of cements a certain image of the dragon and how many legs it has. It's possible, I think, that the popularity of Game of Thrones and House of the dragon and how many legs it has. It's possible, I think, that the popularity of Game of Thrones and House of the Dragon may recalibrate that because in House of the Dragon, the dragons have two legs, but they also have kind of wings that can be used as legs. So the kind of the joints of their wing membranes are kind of like the front legs. So they kind of have two legs, they kind of have four legs.
我愿意认为有。而且我也认为，我们谈到了印刷术如何巩固了龙的某种形象以及它有多少条腿。我认为，《权力的游戏》和《龙之家族》的流行以及它有多少条腿，可能会重新校准这一点，因为在《龙之家族》中，龙有两条腿，但它们也有可以用作腿的翅膀。所以它们翅膀膜的关节有点像前腿。所以它们有点像有两条腿，有点像有四条腿。
And I guess the reason for that is partly because they look more realistic like that. They look more credible, but possibly also, and this is going back to dinosaurs, or the age of the dinosaurs rather, there are giant winged creatures, pterosaurs, vast, vast pterosaurs, Quetzalcoatlus, it's called, 12 foot tall, kind of 40 foot wingspan. And these are often shown on kind of CGI generated portrayals of prehistoric life going around like the dragons in Game of Thrones and House of the Dragon. And I wonder whether perhaps that is an influence on it. And so I wonder whether when you watch House of the Dragon and you see the kind of dragons that you have there, maybe history is being made in exactly the way that it was being made in the 15th century when Mallory was writing about dragons in the Morte d'Arthur.
我想原因部分是因为它们看起来更真实。它们看起来更可信，但可能还有，这要回到恐龙，或者恐龙时代，有巨大的有翼生物，翼龙，巨大、巨大的翼龙，风神翼龙，它被称为，12英尺高，大约40英尺翼展。这些通常显示在史前生活的CGI生成描绘中，像《权力的游戏》和《龙之家族》中的龙一样四处走动。我想知道这是否对它有影响。所以我想知道当你观看《龙之家族》并看到你在那里得到的龙时，也许历史正在以马洛里写关于《亚瑟之死》中的龙时在15世纪发生的方式被创造出来。
Just on dragons more generally as we reach the end, how much do you think the popularity of these dragon stories, so particularly the most recent iterations, how much does that reflect a kind of fear of the apocalyptic? You know, we talked at the beginning about them as tactical nuclear weapons. Obviously, we live in an age of tremendous anxiety about weapons of mass destruction, about the climate, about all of those kinds of things. How much do you think that dragons have become avatars for our deeper, more profound fears about humanity
关于龙更广泛地，当我们接近尾声时，你认为这些龙故事的流行，特别是最近的迭代，在多大程度上反映了一种对末日的恐惧？你知道，我们在开头谈到了它们作为战术核武器。显然，我们生活在一个对大规模杀伤性武器、气候、所有这些事情充满巨大焦虑的时代。你认为龙在多大程度上成为了我们对人类更深层、更深刻恐惧的化身
in the world and whatnot i mean tolkien was writing the hobbit in the 30s so before the development of of the atom bomb i think that the portrayal of dragons in george rr martin must be influenced by that in particular by kind kind of dread of nuclear war, because that's the role that they play. In Tolkien, it's about anxiety, it's about avarice and about accumulation of wealth. And in George R.R. Martin, the dragons are emblems of power. Yeah. Or actually that's something that Tolkien and George R.R. Martin have in common, right? The fear of power and the human capacity to abuse power. All right, Tom, that was absolutely fascinating. Brilliant interweaving of all these different traditions
在世界上等等，我的意思是托尔金在30年代写《霍比特人》，所以是在原子弹发展之前。我认为乔治·R·R·马丁对龙的描绘一定受到那个的影响，特别是某种对核战争的恐惧，因为那是它们扮演的角色。在托尔金那里，它是关于焦虑，它是关于贪婪和财富的积累。而在乔治·R·R·马丁那里，龙是权力的象征。是的，或者实际上那是托尔金和乔治·R·R·马丁共同点，对吧？对权力的恐惧和人类滥用权力的能力。好吧，汤姆，这绝对令人着迷。所有这些不同传统的精彩交织
and forensic work on your part. Thank you very much. Thank you for that. I was going to say, is it draconian? Because that's a different route, isn't it? I was going to say a draconian tour de force. Well, I mean, if you burn down a town with a dragon, that's quite draconian behavior.
以及你方面的法医工作。非常感谢。谢谢你。我本来想说，它是严酷的（draconian）吗？因为那是另一条路线，不是吗？我本来想说一个严酷的杰作。好吧，我的意思是，如果你用龙烧毁一个城镇，那是相当严酷的行为。
That's very Game of Thrones. Right, so on that bombshell, as as it were yeah tom what are you doing this evening reading up on st george for our next podcast presumably are you uh no i will be watching uh season uh two of house of dragon well so will i i'm very excited about it because i understand that the great houses of westeros are heading for a final showdown for a confrontation for the throne. The Greens against the Blacks. Five new dragons, Tom.
那非常《权力的游戏》。好吧，那么在那颗重磅炸弹上，正如人们所说，是的，汤姆，你今晚要做什么？为我们的下一个播客阅读圣乔治，大概是吗？你是，呃，不，我将观看《龙之家族》第二季。好吧，我也是，我对此感到非常兴奋，因为我了解到维斯特洛的大家族正走向最后的摊牌，走向王座的对抗。绿党对黑党。五条新龙，汤姆。
Love new dragons. It's going to be tremendous scenes. So I'm very much looking forward to that. And I should be tuning in on Sky tonight. With the realm divided and on the brink of civil war, Tom, all must choose their side. Brilliant. Bye-bye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
喜欢新龙。这将是巨大的场景。所以我非常期待。我今晚会收看天空电视台。随着王国分裂并处于内战边缘，汤姆，所有人都必须选择他们的立场。精彩。再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。